اللاعب الفرنسي كريم بنزيما اللاعب نادي
الاتحاد السعودي اقلع من مدريد الى جده
صباح اليوم استعدادا لحفل استقباله اللي
راح يقام على ملعب الملك عبد الله الجوهره
بكره من بعد ما تمت مراسم التوقيع على عقد
بينه وبين نادي الاتحاد يوم الاثنين
لثلاثه مواسم الحماس مال المنصات من وقت
ما نشر النادي صوره بنزيما طالع الطياره
ومن بعدها نشر بنزيما نفسه صورته في
الطياره وكتب عليها هيرويجو مع علم
السعوديه الحفل بكره راح يكون مجاني
لجماهير الاتحاد وراح يكون موجود 60 الف
مشجع بينهم رابطه الاقتراحة الاتحاد وراح
يكون في شعل الناريه في الملعب للترحيب
بنزيما وراح ينقل على قنوات النادي
الرسميه ومن نصف ساعه كمان نشر النادي
رابط التقديم على تذاكر حفل استقبال
بنزيما طيب خلينا
وامس كان خلينا نقول انه امس كان نشر
النادي بيان عن ضم بنزيما واعتبروا الصفقه
من اكبر الانتقالات شهره وتاثيرا في نشر
او تاريخ النادي وتضاف لي الخطوات
التاريخيه لرحله الدوري السعودي للمحترفين
اللي بيعزز من مكانته كوجهه لافضل
اللاعبين بالعالم طيب اما بنزيما فقال انه
متحمس لخوض تجربه جديده في بلد جديد وقال
انه نادي الاتحاد عنده تاريخ مذهل ومشجعين
حماسيين وطموحات كبيره وانه هو دائما كان
بيشعر بحفاوه الاستقبال في السعوديه وراح
يعمل بمساعده زملائه في النادي لنقل
الاتحاد لمستويات وافاق جديده وقال كمان
انه على علم بقوه الدوري السعودي وخاصه
بعد قدوم نجوم مثل كريستيانو رونالدو وقال
انه اهدافه بالفوز ما راح تختلف عن لما
كان في اوروبا بعدها شفنا بايو بنزيما على
تويتر تغير وصار وصفه اللاعب كره القدم في
نادي الاتحاد وكان كشف رئيس نادي الاتحاد
انوار الحائلي في البيان عن رقم قميص
بنزيما وقالوا رقمه مع الاتحاد راح يكون
تسعه مثل ما كان مع الريال وعبر عن سعادته
الكبيره بالتعاقد معه ونشر من بعدها
النادي فيديو من لحظات توقيع العقد
انا متحمس اشوفكم في جده
وحقيقه من امس وحساب نادي الاتحاد برحب
ببنزيما على طريقه او طرقه الخاصه ومن بين
صوره لرباط يد بنزيما وقت ما كان يحطوا
بسبب اصبعه المكسور واللي كان رافض يعمل
اللي يعمل له اي عمليه علشان ما يتغيب عن
صفوف نادي السابق ريال مدريد لاشهر النادي
نشر صوره لرباط يد بنزيما وعلق عليها
الاحلام تنتزع وبنزيما رد على الصوت وكتب